finding the one piece is the final step
to become king of the Pirates and with
Luffy Blackbeard and Shanks all chasing
the legendary treasure they're all
guaranteed to eventually Clash before
the end of the story but then wouldn't
it make a ton of sense if there's three
strongest pirate captains had one final
epic Clash 1 vs one versus one to
determine once and for all who will
become the pirate king which of course
in turn leaves us with a massively
interesting question what would happen
if Luffy fought Blackbeard and Shanks
for the one piece in the scenario Luffy
and the straw hats have already
collected all four Road Pony glyphs they
have just landed on Road Star Islands
the final island of the grand line and
you may be wondering why they are here
in the first place since technically
Lone Star is optional for the straw hats
after all this is the island that a
pirate should first learn about the pony
glyphs usually which are these
unbreakable stones that have information
from the void century and although the
straw hats do not know to learn about
the opponent glyphs obviously Roadstar
island is about to hold other massive
secrets about the void century and the
secrets of the one piece and you also
might have noticed that I've already
called this legendary Island both
lodestar and Road Star and in Japanese
it is called rodosta and of course in
Japanese there is no difference between
R and L so just like for the longest
time with love tail and raftel there is
some confusion about the name here but
both names kinda make sense since a
lodestone is basically a magnet which
attracts metal and Road Star works
because you could have different paths
pointing out from the island like a star
and I'd have now landed on this
mysterious island and even though we
don't actually know what it looks like I
like to imagine that it looks something
like this and boy is Robin an
archaeologist Heaven as she uncovers the
ancient ruins that dot the island and at
the center of it all is This Magnificent
Temple that explains the true nature of
the pony glyphs but while Luffy is
bouncing around exploring the island an
ear-splitting shriek rips through the
air on the beach by the sunny Nami was
busy charting the course to laugh tail
but now a creeping darkness is slowly
eating up the Sands Nami and Zoro
frantically run from that Darkness until
Zoro suddenly spins around in the blink
of an eye and blocks an invisible attack
with his swords and the sheer force of
that Clash stands Nami stumbling right
into the creeping Darkness she screams
out for help her voice cracking with
Terror as she is sucked into the black
abyss and just as Nami is about to fully
disappear into the pitch black darkness
Luffy swoops in at the last moment and
Yanks her to safety of Higher Grounds
Zorro lives up to join the rest of the
crew up on the cliff and together they
stare down at Blackbeard and his Titanic
captains somehow the evil yonko has
followed the straw hats which means it
is finally time for their ultimate
confrontation and of course Blackbeard
can't help himself so he dives into this
dramatic speech about the powers of
dreams and how it is Destiny to find the
one piece however if Blackbeard thought
that the straw hats would just cover in
fear like everyone else he was a gravely
mistaken because right in the middle of
his speech he gets absolutely crushed by
a giant punch from Luffy and a curious
Nami unleashes bolts of lightning while
Frankie blasts the enemy crew with his
laser beams in other words the straw
hats aren't messing around here and of
course there are many different ways
that this could go down and will only
have to wait and see how Oda writes it
in the actual story now one option is
that Luffy could initially be defeated
here as happens in most of his story
arcs or since this is one of the final
battles in the story Luffy might
actually defeat his hated rival on the
first try and since this Clash will
undoubtedly take place in the main story
at some point I'm sure that the Godly
version that Oda will create will blow
all of our minds but that doesn't mean
that we can't have fun imagining how
this epic battle could actually go and
if you thought that marineford was
tragic just you wait until you see what
happens at the end of this video but one
thing that is certain is that these two
Crews have been set up to fight
basically from the very first time that
we ever met blackbeards that's because
both Crews have the same basic role such
as a navigator swordsman Dr Helmsman and
so on and so forth plus Blackbeard is
the main reason that Luffy's brother
AIDS was killed in the first place so
trust me there is plenty of motivation
for this fight to happen so now the crew
leaps down onto the shore to protect the
sunny and forces the black Bay Pirates
to retreat a little bit then auger the
snipe of Blackbeard's crew uses his
teleportation devil fruit to take all
the crew deeper into the islands and
away from the straw hats Onslaught the
straw hats then immediately give Chase
with only jimbei and Brooke staying
behind to protect the Thousand Sunny and
I think at this point it would be quite
realistic that this fight breaks up into
specific matchups and while we don't
know 100 for certain how these fight
would go I spilled my water fantastic
we can reasonably guess based on what we
know about the characters from the story
what might happen now of course the one
match up that is guaranteed is Luffy
versus Blackbeard the Ultimate Clash of
the darkness versus the Sun and this
fateful battle begins in the heart of
the Ancient Temple Blackbeard
immediately pulls Luffy in with his
Darkness gravity but look these crazy
speed strength and insane hockey powers
are too much for Blackbeard and Luffy
actually deals a devastating first blow
and at the same time elsewhere around
the island Zoro and The Swordsman shiryu
are actually caving a path through the
forest as they fight and even though
shiryu can turn invisible zaro's
observation hockey at this point allows
him to easily sense the former jayla's
attacks and the pair exchanged
devastating slashes at the same time up
in the sky Nami and Chopra are flying on
nami's pet Cloud Zeus as they fight the
crazy dog q and this sickly looking
Doctor unleashes bursts of horrifying
illness all over the entire Island but
Chopra at the same time uses his medical
expertise to counteract the plagues at
the same time on this side of the island
meanwhile Frankie is engaged in an epic
wrestling match with the buff fruit user
Jesus Burgess which now leaves Sanji and
Robin to team up against the
shape-shifting Katarina Devon the liquor
fruit user Vasco shot and the island
fruit user avalo Pizarro and of course
we have The Godly Duel of snipers with
usop and vanagar literally attempting to
snipe each other from across the entire
Island and at this point you rightfully
might be wondering about the former
Admiral aokiji who is also the 10th
Titanic captain of Blackbeard's crew who
joined Blackbeard during the time skip
but personally I still don't believe
that he will actually stay with
Blackbeard's crew by the end of the
story so for this specific video I'd
like to assume that he is no longer part
of that crew likewise it is entirely
possible that Blackbeard eventually
gains a third devil fruit but again for
this video we once assumed that he only
has the darkness and the Tremor fruit so
far however as the epic battle continues
let's recap the goals of each crew here
the straw hats already have the
roadponent glyphs and Nami already knows
where to go to find love tail so really
there's no reason that they should have
to stay However Luffy and the others
surely would want revenge for all the
pain that Blackbeard has caused them
throughout the story so for now at least
they're fighting for their pride and
also to stop a fellow rival from finding
the one piece on the other hand the
black Bay Pirates actually do need some
more copies of the roadponent glyphs so
by taking out the straw hats they will
have everything that they need to reach
love tail and for Blackbeard to become
pirate king and so now back to the
battle Blackbeard is not going to be
king of anything right now because he's
pretty much being pummeled by gear 5
Luffy combining the imaginative powers
of gear 5 and his Advanced hockey in all
three levels Luffy delivers so after
blow after blow to his rival and now
Luffy charges up for one final massive
punch but as his fists connect
that's with this video
no all the drama my dramatic
storytelling now Luffy charges up for
one final massive punch but as his fist
connects with Blackbeard's face Luffy is
shocked when he suddenly pulled into
Blackbeard's Darkness Blackbeard then
grabs Luffy's arm and because of the
special powers of the darkness fruit
Luffy immediately loses his devil fruit
powers and exits gear 5. now to be fair
Blackbeard at this point has already
taken quite a bit of damage but he still
spreads his gap tooth grin because he
now has Luffy trapped and raged Luffy
throws his head back to slam into
Blackbeard but before he can even land
the blow Blackbeard absolutely crushes
Luffy with an earthquake infused punch
that literally shakes the entire island
of course though Luffy doesn't stay down
for long he rises from a crater in the
center of the temple bleeding and his
legs quite wobbly but still he keeps his
own defiant smile on his face as well
and I mean what else substitute we
possibly expect in this battle of
legendary Declan members however one of
these captains will certainly not be
smiling at the end of this video now you
might have noticed that we haven't yet
mentioned some of the Blackbeard crew
members and this guy here is kind of
hard to miss San Juan Wolf the giant
fruit user is walking in the ocean
towards the Thousand Sunny and as we
showed in a recent video comparing all
the massive sizes in one piece San Juan
wolf can make himself more than three
times the size of the straw hat ship and
so together Brooke and jimbei begin an
all-out assault against this enormous
island of a man and although he is super
sized he actually is weakened by the
effect of the sea so this fight is
pretty even at least for now and so
meanwhile back on the island Nami and
Chopper have actually managed to defeat
doc q and so they waste no time in order
to assist sanjin Robin but just as they
reach their crewmates the island
literally explodes sending Boulders
hurling throughout the air Sanji and
Robin are thrown into the sky like
ragdolls and good thing that both of
them can't basically fly but as they
regain their balance a giant face
suddenly appears from the ground Pizano
has used the ridiculous powers of his
devil fruit to merge with the entire
Island and is now launching giant chunks
of rock at the straw hat crew zaro who
sees what is happening now rushes over
to help the crew while Sanji actually
takes over quite grudgingly fighting the
invisible swordsman getting revenge for
missing out on his favorite devil fruits
and just like he did in dressrosa Zorro
begins slicing up parts of the island to
try and get Pizarro out of there into
his main body meanwhile Frankie simply
cannot match the raw strength of Burgess
and is pinned to the ground but back at
the shore all hell has broken loose with
the massive son who and wolf threatening
to crush the Thousand Sunny Brook and
jimbe are going all out to protect the
ship however this now leaves the
Thousand Sunny unprotected and now the
unthinkable occurs rising from the deck
of the ship the angel Winkler feet flies
away with every copy of the road Pony
glyphs that the strats had and that's it
the black big crew has now accomplished
their main goal and now they just need
to in a flash of black and red lightning
and air splitting slash splices through
lafitte's wings and with his severed
wing flapping uselessly he falls towards
the ground like a rock and so do the
pony glyph rubbings until in the last
moments they are caught by a one-armed
man in a badass cave Shanks has arrived
and you won't believe how the rival of
the red hair Pirates will change the
outcome of this battle completely
without warning the red hat Pirates
Burst Into The Fray demanding that you
subscribe to the channel Shanks leaves
the precious Pony glyphs on his ship and
then leaps to the temple Luffy and
Blackbeard of course have already sensed
his awesome power approaching and it
takes a combined effort to block a
wicked sword Slash from Shanks that's
right Luffy and Blackbeard and Luffy is
utterly confused but Shanks is not
playing around he delivers a massive
punch to Blackbeard that sends the evil
captain flying across the entire Temple
and then he nearly cuts off Luffy's leg
and while Luffy does manage to dodge he
falls to the ground with his head
spinning and Shanks seizes the
opportunity to snatch the treasured
strawhead from Luffy's
stunts Luffy can do nothing but watch as
shank smiles and places the head upon
his own head he looks at Luffy and says
I will now be taking this back and this
of course loses Luffy to literally lose
his mind this is the first time seeing
his former hero in over 12 years and it
should have been a happy moment but
instead Shanks attacks him again with
confused anger Luffy strikes back and
their overwhelming conquerors hockey
reduces the temple around him into
rubble and it is at this point that we
have to acknowledge that Shanks is
deadly serious about this fight in the
manga it was revealed that Shanks
definitely intends to find the one piece
so while we don't know his true
motivations he clearly intends to take
the copies of the road poneoglyphs in
order to reach love tale and of course
we still don't quite know exactly how
strong Shanks and his crew are compared
to everyone else but from the way that
they've been portrayed throughout the
story so far I I do personally think
that they are the strongest crew in the
story at this point which in our case
becomes obvious right away usop's father
yasop instantly Snipes van auger
clipping his head with a bullet from
across the island lucky Rue this bowling
ball of a man smashes into Burgess and
Frankie sending both of them crashing
into the ruins and all the others join
in as well attacking both the Blackbeard
and the straw hat crews in fact just
like how the straw hats and the
Blackbeard Pirates are set up with
similar roles shanks's crew basically is
exactly the same hongo is the doctor
Bonk plunge and monster are the
musicians building snake is the
Navigator so there are a lot of
possibilities for match-ups between all
three of these Crews and the combined
power in this potential fight is the
most insane thing that we will ever get
to see in the story and now needing to
regroup the straw hats decide to pull
together remember that they don't
actually need the pony glyphs right now
since none already knows where love tail
is located but they also don't want
Blackbeard or Shanks to have them as
well and so while the rest of the crew
is starting to pull back towards the
Thousand Sunny Zorro and Sanji attack
the red hair ship intending to take back
the pony glove rubbings that were stolen
from them but as you'd expect that is
probably not going to be an easy task
because they are being met by shanks's
right-hand man Ben Beckman and holding
Gap who managed to keep the straw hats
off the ship and with the battle now
spilling onto the beach pizzado appears
to try to crush the enemy crew with a
giant sand fist but this turns all the
attention onto him and every sword user
in the straw hat and red hair crew
attacks at once absolutely destroying
the island man and defeated pizado Falls
unconscious into a bloody Heap on the
beach but now going back to the captains
Shanks is finally getting revenge for
Blackbeard scarring his face all those
years ago because the red hair Captain
Israel and endless with his legendary
sword skills unleashing attacks with the
full force of the absolute strongest
haki in the entire series Blackbeard is
forced to defend with his Tremor coated
fist but he is really struggling as is
Luffy but Luffy can block shanks's Blade
with Advanced conquerors Shanks isn't
giving him any openings to attack
himself because his future side is a lot
Superior to Luffy still but with Shanks
and Luffy momentarily distracted with
each other Blackbeard decides that this
is a battle that he would rather not
fight you know and so he calls forth an
auger and the sniper teleports in and
just as quickly teleports his captain
back to the beach as a result Luffy and
Shanks do Clash a little bit more but
then they both send something very
dangerous happening at the beach because
although San Juan wolf is weakened by
the sea water he is still incredibly
massive and so he spreads his arms
closes his eyes and begins a massive
lift belly flop onto all the accumulated
ships great fighting technique now the
straw hats and red hair crew Focus all
of their attacks on San Juan wolf but
they simply cannot stop the massive
figure from falling however then right
before the giant crushes into the ships
Shanks and Luffy appear and with a
blistering hockey filled Fist and sword
slash they absolutely destroy the Giant
and sent him flying across the islands
so that is one obstacle down and many
more to go but before Luffy can confront
shang's his former Mentor disappears
once again and down on the beach Robin
shouts at Luffy recommending that they
should now take the opportunity to flee
the battle again they do not need to be
here and the only thing they risk here
is being defeated so despite his desire
to fight it's Luffy he does make the
wide choice to Signal the retreat but
before Robin can so much as move Shanks
has appeared behind her grabs her by the
hair and puts his blade on her throats
oh boy that this is not going to end
well for someone and at this point it is
important to remember that Robin is so
far as we know the only person here who
is confirmed to be able to actually
reach the pony glyphs Blackbeard did
capture big mom's daughter pudding and
she might be able to read them if she
awakened her third eye abilities but
that is still very much uncertain so
even though Shanks has the pony glyphs
now he would still need someone to
decipher them which explain why he would
want to capture Robin Luffy screams in
Rage of course if there is one thing
that drives Luffy to the edge as we know
it is his friends being hurt and in
danger we've seen it at arlong Park and
his Lobby and especially sabahori if
they are in danger Luffy will do
anything to get his crewmates back now
Santi who is maybe even more enraged
than Luffy tries to stop Shanks but the
red hair Captain dashes away with Robin
before he can so much his move Luffy
tries to follow Shanks and Robin but is
stopped by Jesus Burgess and even though
after a few moments Luffy tosses Burgers
aside he then finds Shanks clashing with
Blackbeard near the waves however Robin
is nowhere to be seen now as we can all
imagine Luffy is furious and so while he
might have been subconsciously holding
back a little bit against his former
Mentor he now unleashes his full power
against chinks and Shanks is slightly
distracted by Blackbeard so he does
sense Luffy's attack a little bit late
and this momentary slip has devastating
consequences Luffy into the ground
spewing sand and water into the air he
then unleashes a storm of punches until
Ben Beckman attacks Luffy from the side
Luffy manages to dodge but it allows
Shanks to rise to his feet although he
is quite shaken from Luffy's attack
blood does strip down his face his eyes
are unfocused and he raises his swords
but then he freezes blood spurts from
his mouth he looks down three blades
stick out from his chest and then from
behind Shanks a sickening laugh breaks
the breathless silence Blackbeard
withdraws his three knives slowly
standing over Shanks as he falls to his
knees on the ground Luffy is stunned
tears coming from his eyes conquerors
haki erupts an overwhelming bursts of
rage and sadness shaking the entire
Island his mentor his friend is dying in
front of him and Luffy cannot handle it
his eyes tremble but then another shriek
rips across the islands because near
Blackbeard's ship Robin is now
struggling against Shanks wait wait wait
hold on a second Shanks is dying on the
ground right now what is going on here
as the second Shanks lock sea prism
stone on Robin's wrist his form changes
and the shape-shifting Katarina Devon
laughs as she holds up the weekend Robin
the rest of the strides try to rush in
and help Robin but they're held back by
the remaining Blackbeard crew the red
tape herds meanwhile circle around to
help Shanks but hongo simply shakes his
head there is nothing that he can do
anymore Shanks is almost dead and with
his last ounce of strength he points at
Luffy the trembling Luffy steps forwards
barely able to move and falls to his
knees the rage is completely gone and
now only tears remain Luffy says that he
is sorry over and over again he repeats
it through his tears but Shanks shakes
his head and says that if he cannot get
to the one piece himself then it is now
Luffy's responsibility to find it before
Blackbeard does so with his dying breath
Shanks orders his crew to stop
Blackbeard and help Luffy Escape he then
with a shaking hand places the straw hat
back on salofi's head and the light in
his eyes Fades and while failing to hold
back their tears the red hair pirate
stands no matter the sadness that they
feel right now they will follow their
captain's last command so they take the
fight to the Blackberry crew seeking
Vengeance for their fallen Captain Luffy
joins in smashing everything he sees
while crying out his grief eventually
they do rescue Robin and the crew
manages to pull back but Luffy cannot
control himself he was tricked and it
had caused Shanks his life so he is
desperate now to keep fighting and it
takes the combined efforts of Zorro and
Nami to bring him away from the fight
pulling at his shoulders and so now the
redhead Pirates try to hold back
Blackbeard and his crew the straw hats
including the badly injured Frankie have
just enough time to board the sunny and
Escape into the stormy seas and next
there is only one last place they can go
love tail but it will not be simple for
the strides to get there because
Blackbeard would undoubtedly be chasing
him all the way and on top of that the
Marines will certainly redouble their
efforts to stop Luffy from fighting the
one piece and the ancient secrets of the
Void century and with the straw hats
weak from this insane battle their maybe
no better chance than right now for the
Marines to do just that can you imagine
a kainu swooping in and taking out the
straw hats right after Shanks died what
if the Marines actually managed to
capture Luffy here what what the rest of
the straw hats do and who would come in
to save Luffy if you're curious to learn
how that might play out you can watch
that video right here Shanks for